if we really want to help law
enforcement protect Americans from
homegrown extremists the kind of
tragedies that occurred at San
Bernardino and that now have occurred in
Orlando there is a meaningful way to do
that we have to make it harder for
people who want to kill Americans to get
their hands on weapons of war that let
them kill dozens of innocents it is
absolutely true we cannot prevent every
tragedy but we know that consistent with
the Second Amendment there are
common-sense steps that could reduce gun
violence and could reduce the lethality
of somebody who intends to do other
people harm we should give ATF the
resources they need to enforce the gun
laws that we already have people with
possible ties to terrorism who aren't
allowed on a plane shouldn't be allowed
to buy a gun enough talking about being
tough on terrorism actually be tough on
terrorism and stop making it easy as
possible for terrorists to buy assault
weapons reinstate the assault weapons
ban make it harder for terrorists to use
these weapons to kill us otherwise
despite extraordinary efforts across our
government by local law enforcement by
our intelligence agencies by our
military despite all the sacrifices that
folks make these kinds of events are
going to keep on happening